I've got some great video to play for
you here
this is video of how democrats should be
addressing
so much of the nonsense being done by
Republicans both of these [ __ ] Clips are
from Democratic governor Gavin Newsom of
California now whoa whoa whoa whoa David
sir
I know
you don't have to like Gavin newsom's
politics
or that French Laundry coveted dinner
during the time of all sorts of shutdown
guidelines okay to recognize that he
gets the tone and the language that
Democrats have to be using now it seems
pretty clear that Newsome is positioning
himself to run for president or for the
Democratic nomination in 2024. great
good for him when we get the full list
of who's running I will evaluate the
options and tell you who I support right
now the issue is he gets that there
needs to be a certain Edge and
ruthlessness to how Democrats go after
Republicans check out this first clip
this is from a Texas Tribune event over
the weekend where Gavin Newsom is asked
about the busing of migrants that's been
done as a political Stunt by Texas and
California I'm Sorry by Texas and
Florida
um and he morally flip frames the entire
thing correctly take a listen look it's
clear that DeSantis broke the law
question is which law did he break
did he break the laws of his own state
did he break federal law
but one thing he did is he broke with
precedent any precedent of decency and
honor
his lack of character on display he
comes into another state your state to
try to find Pawns in a political game
rounds them up sends them to an island
and then fundraises off it
what does that say about his character
and the character of the Republican
party that celebrated that act of
Cruelty and dehumanization so
I I called it out because I I find it
offensive and disgraceful and I find it
increasingly
normalized now in the Republican party
it's certainly well established here
with Greg Abbott who is apparently
getting more tension on this topic than
Ron DeSantis and he wanted in
and I mean that and that's what's
happened to the Republican party in this
country and that needs to be called out
and Ron DeSantis rightfully is being
called out but by not enough people and
that's what concerns me particularly
with the silence the appalling silence
within the Republican party yeah he is
completely right these issues need to be
framed morally as the morally decrepit
failures that they are by the party the
Republicans who claim the Moral Majority
they claim to Value life and the Dignity
of life when you use
immigrants awaiting Asylum adjudication
as political pawns lie to them to get
them on planes not to Boston for jobs as
they were promised but to Martha's
Vineyard as Martha's Vineyard shuts down
for the winter and goes into off season
where there's no jobs on this tiny
Island
to make political points and to score
political points with people's lives
it's not the dignity and respect for
life that they claim to have and Newsome
gets it here's another clip of Newsome
and again you don't have to say this guy
aligns with me on every political view
to recognize that there's a very few
Democrats that are actually talking
about these issues in this way and
framing them in this way Katie Porter is
really good at it Pete boot Edge is
really good at it
there aren't that many people that are
that good at what he is doing and
Newsome here making the point
the santis is just a bully we didn't
treat bullies kindly when I was a kid I
like Charlie Chris and I I don't like by
the way the context here is that
Newsome is explaining he donated to
Charlie Christ who's the Democrat
running against Ron DeSantis for
governor of Florida
do you want to ask what my why is in
life I don't like bullies I don't like
people that demean people I don't like
people talk down to people I didn't like
what DeSantis said about fat she though
he may disagree with him but to call
someone pejorative terms because they're
short and who the hell raised these guys
what kind of people are they
I mean I know all of us had a you know
sit there and suck it up and take
Trump's demonization but not everybody
has to act like him
I mean literally I I remember growing up
and folks would have their mouths washed
out with soap if they talked like this I
got four kids I don't want these guys to
be models the attacking LGBT community
attacking women I mean this guy's so
extreme you rape and incest Rhonda
Santos talks about freedom and a young
girl is raped by her father
doesn't have the right to her own body
to make her own decisions sick spare me
Freedom there's no Freedom there's no
choice so yeah I'm standing up as a
human being
got to use those dollars and I hope
others of you send money to send a
message that uh if that's the future of
the damn Republican party this country
is in real trouble and that's what we've
been saying for a long time the left has
the moral High Ground on so many of
these issues the left has the moral High
Ground on the abortion issue the right
likes to claim it for themselves but
what is important is can you articulate
it clearly and many Democrats struggle
to articulate that moral High Ground
clearly and what I like about Newsome is
that he is doing that now we can talk
about who should represent Democrats on
the presidential ticket in 2024 if Joe
Biden doesn't run that's a different
question than is Newsom striking the
right tone and getting down to the Crux
really the kernel of of Truth
fundamental truth here about the
disgusting nature of what the Republican
party has become I believe that he is
now Chris has a very much uphill battle
uh in in Florida and we've looked at the
polling there it doesn't look
particularly good for Charlie Crist but
that's a different question than is this
the language and the tone that democrats
should be using I believe the answer is
yes if you disagree with me or if you
agree with me let me know I want to hear
from you one of our sponsors is little
spoon your One-Stop shop for healthy
easy meals and snacks for your baby
toddler or big kid delivered right to
your door with fresh organic baby food
for every stage toddler and kids meals
that even the picky eaters will love and
the new line of healthy smoothies little
spoon has you covered little spoon makes
everything fresh it's just like homemade
it's ready in mere moments all of the
recipes are delicious they're
nutritionally balanced and free of junk
little spoons baby food is 100 organic
and cold pressed for every eating stage
for toddlers and kids little spoon has
the classics Mac mac and cheese but
they'll sneak things in like butternut
squash and carrots they have more
adventurous meals cheesy pupusas or
chicken pot stickers they're all kid
approved packed with nutrients and
little spoons organic smoothies are
perfect when you need something quick
and easy and the best part is kids meals
under six dollars and baby food and
smoothies under three dollars each plus
you'll get fifty percent off your first
order when you go to littlespoon.com and
use the coupon code Pacman 50. the link
is down below